you're described as a very habitual
person where did that come from
oh that might have come from the tim
ferriss podcast uh i i don't think i'm
more habitual than anybody else i think
human beings are entirely creatures of
habit uh you know as a young children
are born with no habit loops they're
they're essentially born as blank slates
uh and then they habituate themselves to
think they learn patterns and they get
conditioned and they use that to get
through everyday life and habits are
good you know habits can allow you to
uh background process certain things so
that your your neocortex your
your frontal lobe stays available to
solve brand new problems
but we also unconsciously pick up habits
in the background and we keep them for
decades and we may not realize that
they're bad for us so we're ready to
move on from them
to some extent you know our attitude in
life our mood our happiness levels
depression levels these are also habits
uh do we judge people
how often do we eat what kinds of food
do we eat do we walk or do we sit do we
move do we exercise do we read these are
habits as well uh and we you absolutely
need habits to function you cannot solve
every problem in life as if it's the
first time that's thrown at you but
but what we do is we accumulate all
these habits we put them in the bundle
of identity uh ego ourselves and then we
get attached to that i'm shane this is
the way i am i'm devol this is the way i
am uh and it's really important to be
able to uncondition yourself to be able
to take your habits apart and say oh
okay well that's that's a habit that i
probably picked up from when i was a
toddler and i was trying to get my
parents attention
and now i just reinforced it and
reinforced and reinforced it and i
called it part of my identity but is it
serving me anymore is it making me
happier is it making me healthier is it
making me accomplish whatever i want to
set out to accomplish right now so i
don't think i'm any more in fact i would
argue i'm less habitual than most people
like i don't like to structure my day uh
but
to the extent that i do have habits i'm
trying to make them more deliberate
rather than
accidents of history so what's a habit
that you're trying to to change right
now what are you working on
well i i did a lot of habit changes the
last few years so i've now got a daily
workout that i do which is a great habit
i
cut down heavily on drinking
it's not fully eliminated but it's
mostly gone i drop caffeine
uh i'm not on the paleo diet although i
like to be so i'm in a variation of it
that i call the failure diet which is i
try to be paleo but i failed constantly
but i don't beat myself up over it
because i feel that even approximating
towards it is better than where i have
been historically
um so you know like that uh i tried to
build a meditation habit but i but i
failed but i have made a habit of being
meditative
so i've gone through lots of habits uh
probably the one that i'm currently
would like to cultivate is doing yoga
more regularly but i haven't really
i haven't formulated a plan around that
and by the way i reject a lot of the
stuff that's being peddled around today
about how you perform in break habits i
know there's this very popular book one
that i even recommended which talks
about the science behind habits and one
of its depression conclusions i think
this came out of stanford was that you
can't break habits you can only replace
them uh and that's bs i've definitely
broken habits completely
and so i think you can uncondition
yourself you can't untrain yourself it's
just hard
so it just takes work it takes effort
and usually the big habit changes come
when they're strong desire motivators
attached to them
um so the you know the yoga one i'm
going to work on i don't yet have a
great plan on that one i haven't tackled
that one properly yet
a big habit that i'm working on which is
going to be really hard to explain in
any way that any normal human being will
understand this but i'm trying to turn
off my monkey mind
uh you know
like i think we are when we're born as
children we're pretty blank slates we're
living very much in the moment
uh and we're essentially just reacting
to our environment through our instincts
and we're living in what i would call
the real world
and then when puberty comes along it's
the onset of desire it's the first time
you really really want something
and you start long-range planning for it
uh and then because of that you start
thinking a lot and you start building an
identity and ego to go and get what you
want and this is all normal and healthy
it's part of being the human animal
but i think at some point it gets out of
control and then we are constantly just
talking to ourselves in our heads we're
playing little movies in our heads
walking down the street but no one's
actually there now of course you started
voicing this thought in your head that
you're always having you'd be a madman
and they'd lock you up but the reality
is if you walk down the street a
thousand people in the street i think
all thousands are talking to themselves
in their head at any given point they're
constantly judging everything that they
see they're playing back movies of
things that happened to them yesterday
they're living in fantasy worlds of
what's going to happen tomorrow
and they're just pulled out of base
reality and that can be good when you're
doing long-range planning it can be good
when you're solving problems it's good
for the survival and replication
machines that we are but i think it's
actually very bad for your happiness
and so
in my mind the the mind should be a
servant or a tool my master it's not
something that should be controlling me
and driving me 24 7. so
i've taken on this idea that
i want to break the habit of
uncontrolled thinking
which is hard because if i say to you
don't think of a pink elephant i just
put a pink elephant in your head
so it's it's it's an almost impossible
problem so it's more something that has
to be guided by feel
than guided by actual thinking or
thought process
but i'm deliberately cultivating
experiences
states of mind locations activities
that will help me get out of my mind
and i know you know all of society does
that to some extent in some sense the
the
people chasing thrills and action sports
or flow states or
orgasms or any of these states that
people really strive to get to a lot of
these are basically just trying to get
out of your own head they're trying to
get away from that voice in your head
and this over developed sense of self at
the very least i do not want my sense of
self to continue to develop and become
stronger as i get older i want it to be
weaker and more muted
so that i can live much more in present
everyday reality and accept nature and
the world for what it is
and appreciate it very much in the
childhood
and then not have to seek
happiness through external circumstances
chasing to fit some preconceived notion
that i have
wow there's a lot there i want to ask
questions on is there yeah that's a
tough one that'll take years that's
that's not a six month habit that's a
ten year habit the simplest way to do
this is to scale a habit down uh so in
the book i talk about this thing i call
the two minute rule
and the idea is you just take whatever
habit you're trying to build and you
scale it down to the first two minutes
and i had a i had a reader who did
something similar to this he ended up
losing over 100 pounds and one of the
ways that he did it was he went to the
gym but he wasn't allowed to stay for
longer than five minutes so stay sounds
kind of crazy but for the first six
weeks he went and he showed up and did
like half an exercise and then he would
leave and go home
and to most people they hear that and
they're like well you know it's kind of
ridiculous you're wasting your time
you're not actually going to get in
shape from that but the point is he was
mastering the art of showing up and a
habit has to be established before it
can be improved you know like until you
become the person who shows up every day
there's nothing to optimize we're so
worried about figuring out
the best diet plan or the best business
idea or the optimal way to you know
boost my bench press or whatever
that where we search for all these
perfect plans but we don't do the thing
that is fundamental to all of it which
is just showing up and the two-minute
rule is one way to do that you know you
like you want to do 30 minutes of yoga
well let's translate that into take out
your yoga mat or if you want to read 30
books a year let's translate that into
read one page
but whatever the first two minutes are
the behavior scale it down master that
master the art of showing up make it as
easy as possible to get started and then
once you become that person and you're
going to the gym every day or you're
reading one page every day well now you
have options now you have choices and
you can upgrade and improve from there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you